Elon Musk you know him he created Tesla
and SpaceX he had some interesting
tweets and some comments about how he
fears robots more than he fears nuclear
war let's look at a couple tweets it's
worth reading super intelligence by beau
strim we need to be super careful with
AI artificial intelligence potentially
more dangerous than nukes hope were not
just the biological bootloader for
digital super intelligence unfortunately
that's increasingly possible now the
book he's talking about is called super
intelligence paths dangers and
strategies by Nick Bostrom we've got an
excerpt from the book
we cannot blithely assume that a super
intelligence will necessarily share any
of the final values stereotypically
associated with wisdom and intellectual
development in humans scientific
curiosity benevolent concern for others
spiritual enlightenment and
contemplation renunciation of material
acquisitiveness a taste for refined
culture or for the simple pleasures in
life humility and selflessness and so
forth now if you've watched the other
clips that we've posted from this
episode we went from Ebola to Isis and
all this other bad stuff in the world I
don't know how much of that all that
good stuff about humanity that he's
talking about we have going on in the
world right now right Elan musk
obviously knows a lot about the future a
lot this is a guy who's on the forefront
of this of getting us off this planet
and at least while we're on this planet
maybe using some electric cars before we
destroy the whole freakin thing how much
credence do you give his tweets and this
idea that the robots are gonna get us
before the nuclear war first of all I
never say never to anything never or
always it's just one of those I do not
put it past anyone to create some kind
of robot oh why would you want to do
that
don't understand why you would want to
create something that's smarter than you
right well isn't it more that we're just
gonna lose control of them if you any of
these scientific sci-fi movies like it's
all that we try to do something good but
then of course they end up taking over
yeah there's a lot of commerce
terminators there's a lot of
conversation this article is about like
a benevolent robot a robot that is kind
of tasked with protecting the humans and
okay let's think of a worst-case
scenario to protect a human is to
protect a human from harming another
human well maybe the best way to protect
them from harming each other to lock
them all into cages
well that which is that was I Robot you
can either read the book or you can see
the Bill Smith movie but that was
exactly what happened the robots turned
because they realized that we were
killing each other so then they turned
up my problem with these kinds of
arguments and yes I would argue that
Elon Musk is is a futurist I would argue
that he has he has some very good ideas
about how human society can and could
move towards the future
Elon Musk though is not a philosopher
Elon Musk is actually not a scientist
he's a very rich man who hires a lot of
very smart people to do things that he
thinks are good things to do and most of
the time those are very good things to
do but let's not you know put him on a
really big pedestal
second to that I think that there is a
this entire conversation is predicated
on the idea that artificial intelligence
is capable of what you're talking about
many scientists don't think that's the
case we have futurists like Ray Kurzweil
or Michio Kaku who think there's gonna
be a singularity we're going to be
downloaded into the internet and we're
not going to need our physical bodies
anymore and I saw the matrix yeah a lot
a lot a lot of neuroscientists and a lot
of computational neuroscientist computer
engineers who work in that field are
very skeptical that we will ever get AI
to this place we know we have the
computing power we don't understand
enough about how the brain works to be
able to build a computer that computer
they admit yeah a actual human brain
activity right so that is an interesting
point and that brings me to my next
question is do you think we've already
started this so in other words we have
the technology and we're all walking
around with this stuff in our hand right
an iPhone and we're all doing this stuff
all day long so the technology part is
there and then the the other part the
intelligence part is just us it's our
brains that we're constantly putting
into it all day long with our Twitter
and Instagram and all that so we're
becoming the machines ourselves right oh
yeah but with a brain kind of a computer
that way you know neurons fire and it's
did you know in a certain direction and
like we we're already wired for that in
in a big way you know we just yes we
understand most of us right or wrong and
make we're emotionally intelligent in
that way you just go back to like wow I
mean just why like why I mean like it's
spiders and ants aren't walking around
being like oh I wish you know humans
were made so they can crush us and they
can step on us and destroy us like one
day I just don't I don't understand that
that's interesting so do you think
humans fundamentally have some desire to
destroy ourselves like we love
Godzilla movies and we love destruction
movies is there some weird psyche it's
like because we do sit on the top of the
you know the food pyramid so to speak
it's like there is some fascination with
creating something that is bigger than
us I mean we're already fascinated with
God and the idea of God and the idea of
the bigness you know that there is
something bigger than us like why not
create that weight power real quick does
God exist yes or no no I I think the
issue here well first of all I have to
say the brain and the computer do not
work the same way
fundamentally they don't work the same
way and that's something we have to
understand it's hard to understand that
because the media tells us that they
work the same way because it's easy to
do this analogies like just like in a
computer your brain does this but it's
[ __ ] there are a lot of people who
try to model computers after the human
brain and they've been very successful
making computers smarter and faster and
better what is the fundamental
difference between like the brain and
like the computer and how they're wired
so when we talk about and and this I you
might even want to cut this out we'll
see I'm gonna try and keep it short but
I can tell you just from personal
experience and granted this was you know
almost 10 years ago maybe now when I was
in graduate school I was working in a
neuroscience lab where we took
mouse neurons we took the brain cells
and we put them on these little plates
and we could we could calculate all the
different ways that they fired and I was
working with a physicist who's now at
Los Alamos and he was doing
computational neurophysiology where he
would literally look at three neurons in
a row and he would look at types of
networks and say if this one fires and
this one fires how does this one react
if this one fires and this one fires how
does this one that's three neurons you
have billions of these things in your
brain it's the capabilities of the brain
are so far beyond the computational
power that we understand right now
computers are fast right they can hold a
lot of data but their reasoning
abilities that computers have are
nowhere near the reasoning abilities
that the human brain has been able to
have and funded by the way they can beat
us in jeopardy but they can't below
exactly and also and also I've got to
make this point we still don't know in
the neurosciences how consciousness
arises the concept of self how does it
go from individual neurons to being
awake and alert and aware and until we
understand that which is kind of the
holy grail of neuroscience I have
absolutely no fear that a computer is
going to become self-aware and take over
yeah that's great
final thought how long till we have
human-robot marriage start having sex
right well Trump said 2030 so that's I'm
going with that